it's Saturday night I did a full face of
makeup full hair and I am staying inside
and shooting in YouTube video some
heroes don't wear capes and couldn't
only I happen to not like a Pitt also
not a hero know what's happening here
something that I will hate later once I
edit this video of course it is there we
go I know your life is different now
I love making cooking videos as you guys
know and I mostly love them because it
is only way I clean my kitchen oh no
turn on I asked you guys for suggestions
on what I should cook for this cooking
video and you guys had a lot of a lot of
stuff that you guys wanted some of you
said food someone says make my
depression go away someone said they
wanted me to make not a cooking video so
you know also great helpful suggestions
thank you so much today I decided and
said I'm going to make pasta from
scratch in my mind the most adult things
you can possibly do are your taxes and
make your own pasta and I do my taxes
annually except for that one year but I
haven't ever made my own pasta and I
looked it up on BuzzFeed the source of
all good under 35 year old pertinent
information and I found an article that
sow my bug zapper number I just aligned
myself with a group of people that are
under the age of 35 or in the food
section and I immediately found an
article here's how to make great pasta
from scratch it looks pretty easy not
gun wood we're gonna try it if this
works I'm gonna lose my goddamn eye box
pasta is like infinitely easier than
this but there's such a sense of like
domestic pride is this you know like a
can we take something that is already
like pretty good to eat and easy to make
and like do it harder I just shut that
window because I thought my neighbor was
listening to make this video and I got
embarrassed I don't know why I want this
to work so bad I think some for some
reason to my brain if this is a success
then it's like truly I have like leveled
up slightly more capable human here we
go I went to my bug zapper off because
calm down
the idea of bugs being killed like two
feet to my right is probably not as
appetizing Oh Mia pasta okay and between
this camera and go on because I'm doing
professional welcome today oh wow
this hair makeup looks like someone Bon
Jovi freshly okay heard that the camera
was on and you want to just be in the
way perfect so we need two cups of
all-purpose flour that's what I'm using
you can use different types of flour
apparently and we're just gonna pour
that directly onto this cutting board
they're working on like just their own
counter surface I know me I'm disgusting
by default you are disgusting countertop
because I responsible for taking care of
you also you cutting board but for some
reason you get a pass oh you would think
that they would figure out a better way
to package flour I feel like no matter
what it's just gonna seep out all over
the place that's just an old person
unnecessary ramps one cup cooking is
crazy but this is gonna be pasta then
we're gonna eat two cups so now what
you're supposed to do is you're supposed
to create a well in the middle of the
flour by pushing it all to the side and
it says create a very deep well because
that's we're gonna put eggs in and then
we're gonna slowly mix it all together
we need two large eggs and six egg yolks
oh excuse me the garbage we are family
large eggs and then we need six egg
yolks it's just the yellow part of the
egg wow this is hot been told that you
separate the whites from the yolk
we need six of these let's hit
fast-forward
[Applause]
Oh after explaining that I didn't wash
my hands before sorta then we need a
tablespoon of extra-virgin olive oil I
just got this thing for olive oil
because I love wasting money on
something I don't mean but that gives
off the illusion that like aa tablespoon
okay then we whisk it together I don't
wanna get my whisk out so I'm just gonna
then we're going to do is take our egg
and oil mixture and put it into the
center of our well and slowly start to
mix with a fork our flour and egg
together so we put this and here we go
oh my god so you don't want the eggs to
breach or they get through the wall so
you're just from what I've seen you just
sort of slowly mix it yeah no egg breach
oh she ain't breech oh my god oh my god
it's it's oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god I did that oh my god I panic
I'm panicking I'm panicking up down
misusing my hands oh I'm panicking oh
it's okay Dixon get the flowers oh I'm
panicking oh my god it looks so easy in
the JYP's pleasant gipset the BuzzFeed
article use this is not how you do it
this is not calming mixing you know what
we're just gonna use hands why did we
not think that this is how it would go
why do we possibly think that we could
have done it the way that the very sweet
oh do I look like a timeless Italian
grandmother right now because I really
feel like it every chef has their own
methodology it says incorporated little
by little but sometimes just complete
forced immersion okay
then it says once it starts to become
slightly malleable or like a dough you
can start using your hands so that's
clearly where we're at now and we
basically form it into our pasta dough
and we have to knead it for like seven
to ten minutes it says do not skimp on
the kneading of this god I wanna like
hate that you take a long time with your
kneading but I relate to that so much
ahead so I will spend oh god this isn't
Oh Oh No
what did Homer say when he stopped his
pasta making process job too easy
oh no jobs on the don't eat it don't
even if anything has just really had no
interest in even trying to eat that
dough so bodes well for a pasta yeah
yeah yeah oh god you work like me at the
start relationships clingy we're gonna
need this for seven to ten minutes here
we go this is pretty nuts that this
one's just flour and eggs a second ago I
mean this is some day plain [ __ ] right
here when you think you're done kneading
if you poke the dough and it springs
back to life then that's how you know
you're done super they're ready all
right yeah that's almost back to life
I'll take it so now we need to take some
saran wrap and wrap this up and now we
have to let it sit for an hour think
about what you've done in a second we're
back I saw eight minutes left on my
timer which means to me when I around uh
because of my impatient brain that we're
done
don't wasn't resting for about an hour
in the last 52 minutes
I've given Gusev back Anna and she tried
to fight me and I got sweaty and I hope
house smells like wet dog right now
so domestic goddess at your service I
remembered that I forgot to think of
what kind of pasta dish I want to make I
was just thinking about the short game
of just making the actual pasta forgot
that once you cook it then to make it a
meal you should think about other
ingredients so I think I want to try and
do like a very simple like olive oil
garlic sauce we'll see how that turns
out let's see if we'd get pasta out of
this shall we go first we could throw it
on some flour just to make this
workspace less sticky I'm a cooking chef
it's like sand art isn't that beautiful
it doesn't last nothing is guaranteed
look at but this says to start working
with your dough you want to cut it into
portions and then you put all the other
sections that you're not working with
rolling out back in your saran wrap it
says you gotta roll it thin enough that
you could see your hand through it
that's how transparent and thin this
piece should be this is the part I'm
already bored those I wash it I guess
what you guys think oh why does that
keep happening so I can see my hand
through it you cut it into strips that
will become your pasta oh my god I made
noodles I think okay we're gonna hold
them to the side oh my I am excited and
we have noodles oh my god we have actual
noodles so let's put these in the pot
and cook for like two to three minutes
here come with me ready little journey
noodle journey Betty well okay good luck
to you okay well that cups we're gonna
make some sauce using just olive oil
salt pepper garlic and some sun-dried
tomatoes why the [ __ ] shot let's see
what happens unless I pasta it looks
like pasta I mean that's cooked pretty
well oh my god I think I might have just
made pasta from scratch but we're gonna
add salt pepper and some parsley to the
other sauce ish thanks Hey oh my god
I think we're ready to drain our pasta
can't see it but it looks like pasta oh
my god
oh my god
oh no everything's kind of gross
everything has a little bit of a film on
it which is just like me I didn't buy
any basil I [ __ ] up I didn't buy basil
keep your basil comments to yourself hi
hi friend now you come here oh my god
she made fresh pasta I made pasta from
scratch I'm a genius I can do anything
oh my god you are just powder and eggs a
second ago I made you you owe me you
work for me now oh my god I cannot
believe this I cannot believe this extra
work did I did my cheese egg on previous
Grace's face she did not believe in
current grace enough it she's not by any
accoutrements to make this dish extra
great here let me just show you
[Music]
ah I ripped my jeans more than they're
already torn I honestly can't believe I
did this and I feel as promised I did oh
man that college graduation day which is
not the correct emotional response to
this I feel like a wizard
you gotta eat it though that's the other
part of this is the eating factor oh oh
it's actual noodles sad I just sent
myself some news and I'm so stoked I'm
so proud to be a pervert in this moment
[Music]
okay so one my level of taste of food is
like raccoon level two this is delicious
I can't believe I did this oh my god
doesn't pick newts I'm gonna you know
criticize for criticism is do they're a
little thick for a first time oh my god
that was so relatively easy I can't
believe I did it I can't believe I'm
talking like a commercial for a product
it's supposed to make your life easier
Wow who believed in me who didn't
believe in me leave it in the comments
down below this is where my life is now
where this is where I derive pride from
all right she's fully 32 yo you guys
like this video give it a thumbs up and
let me know the comments on below what
else I should cook what else from
scratch should I attend and don't forget
to subscribe to this YouTube channel I'm
trying to put up more videos recently
hit that fill notification so you know
exactly when I do other than that I
don't know oh my god imagine if an ace
bandage was delicious